[Music]
better
you
[Music]
now
was
[Music]
for
give
[Music]
so
for
hello everyone and welcome to the
table hi guys y it it's not raining at
the moment that's great uh my name is
Abby solman and we I'm so excited to see
so many new faces uh we have a couple of
announcements for tonight uh the first
one being the tables Fall Festival is
coming up next uh Friday November 10th
at Kelly and Josh tilford's house um
this is a night for just our community
to get together eat play games hang out
uh kind of see each other outside of
just the church Sanctuary which is
really nice so that's going to be on
November 10th uh there's a QR code up
here if you want to get more details and
rsbp for that um additionally uh next
week will be our first Sunday Meal which
is where we go to um hat Creek Burger
Company after church as a community um
if you guys want to attend it's really
nice to get to meet some of the
community members outside of the church
as well um one last thing uh before we
get started tonight um I feel like this
weekend was like the epitome of change
of season
for me anyways which is always a really
good time to kind of just take a minute
like a checkin on myself where am I at
take a moment kind of be present um just
with the service tonight I know I heard
listening to these guys earlier it's
really great so um just be excited for
what this evening is going to
bring oh oh there I
am well if you guys will go ahead and
stand with us we're going to get started
[Music]
tonight
if you lost in
know go and figure out
why take a trip to your dark side go on
and have good
cry cuz we're all
lonely we're all
lonely
together
I want to see your
sadness I want to share your sins I want
to bad your blood and I want to be let
in don't you just don't we all just want
to be
together
leave what what's
heavy what's heavy
behind
leave what's
[Music]
heavy what's heavy
behind if your face is
down take a look
around do you fingers move do your lungs
inflate are you tired are you weary of
the Hidden hate you've been
holding did you lose that love have you
never are you feeling sad because you
did a bad
[Music]
thing what
heavy what's heavy
behind
leave what's
heavy what's heavy
[Music]
behind
leave what
heavy what's heavy
[Music]
behind
what's
[Music]
heavy what's heavy
behind all right we will dismiss the
kids we have second through sixth grade
over
here
first four through first grade four
years old through first grade and then
babies up to three is back through those
doors all right we're going to move into
um prayers of the
people
wait okay if you want to read it with
me for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived differ
we pray to you for those experiencing
loss loneliness and disconnection and
for those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to
you
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
come Tear Down the Walls of build every
wall of build every wall of
build cuz you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart every
piece of my My Heart
Lord I am trusting that you are a
faithful father and all that you have it
is good you're a generous Giver your
love's like no other you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again I am bringing my heart to you with
open hand
Closer Closer you're dra me in as the of
my heart before you
again over and over and over again I am
bring my heart with Open Hands closer
and closer you're drawing me in as the
deps of my heart lay before you again
Lord I am trusting that you are faithful
father all that you have it is
good you're a generous Giver your love's
like no you come and break through to
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
close closer and closer you're draw me
in as the dep of my heart lay you
again come Tear Down the Walls I build
up every wall I build up every wall buil
up you deserve every peace of my heart
every pieace of my heart every piece of
my
heart
[Music]
You
Deserve You
[Music]
Deserve come Tear Down the Walls of
build every wall I've built up every
wall I've built up you serve every piece
of my heart every piece of my heart
every piece of my
[Music]
heart
God we know that you're
faithful God we know that you're with
us and if we don't know please help us
to
see sing with me Christ is Christ is my
firm foundation
[Music]
The Rock on which I stand when
everything around me
shaken I've never been more glad cuz I
put my faith in
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful through
generations
so why would he fail
now he
won he
won't I've still got joy in
[Music]
chaos I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be going
under I'm not held by My Own Strength I
build my life on
Jesus he's never let me down faithful in
every
season so why would he fail now he
won't he
won
he won't
[Applause]
fail he won't
fail he
won't he
won't he won't
[Music]
fail he won't
and Rain came wind BL my house was built
on
you and I'm safe with you I'm going to
make it through sing it out rain came
wind BL my house was built on you
I'm save with you I'm going to make it
through and I'm going to make it through
cuz I'm standing strong I'm standing
strong on
you oh I'm going to make it
through cuz my house is built on you
Christ is my firm found
The Rock on I stand when everything
around me
Shen i' never been more glad cuz I put
my faith in
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful through
generations so why would he fail
now he
won't he
won't he won't
fail he won't
fail he
won't he
won
he won't
[Music]
[Applause]
fail he won't
fail he
[Music]
won we know that he is faithful
I know that he is
faithful I know that he's
faithful I know that he is
[Music]
faithful know that he is
faithful I know I know I know that he is
faithful I know I know that he is
faithful I know that he is
faithful I know that he is faithful
I know that he
is I know that he is
faithful I know that he is
faithful I know I know know that he is
faithful I know I know that he is
faithful know I know know that he is
faithful he is
faithful fath he is he is
[Music]
faithful God we thank you so much much
for
[Music]
tonight thank you for the opportunity to
come together and meet
together
yeah God I pray that no matter what we
came in here with tonight that we
would that we would be able to Center on
you and know that you are good and know
that you are faithful to us no matter
what is happening in this world no
matter what people are doing or saying
to us in our around us God I pray You'
help us put our eyes on you and help us
to
see help us to see what is truth what
are you
doing yeah what do you want what is your
heart because we believe that you're
faithful but we look around and we see
the challenges we see the struggle but
we believe you're faithful so please
help us to see what does it look like
for us to follow what does it look like
for us to be in tunee with your
heart
yeah
amen you guys can take a seat and while
you do that turn around say hi to
somebody
[Music]
andace to be with you all um my name is
Brett and uh it is it's a joy to welcome
everyone and that includes those join us
online love youall lots and um
especially anyone who's new be here the
first few times and um we're just really
really glad that you're here Jesus was
um so incredibly
hospitable and we long to be that same
kind of people we're on the journey we
don't always get it right but I hope you
do feel a sense of um just welcome and
and to know that you are welcomed in
this place um so we um well I speak for
myself I am I'm just a little bit raw uh
it's been quite the week and I just came
um we had a dear friend um not part of
this community part of our our previous
church and um she uh passed away it was
it's quite tragic like you know Mom four
in her like mid-40s or so um cut the flu
and or maybe something else that's where
we'll see kind of what plays out but um
so I just had the funeral I didn't
conduct it but I was just you know
attending um at 2 o'cl so I'm likeo kind
of kind of just kind of feeling it you
know um in a way though it's good I'm
like I'm I'm glad it's good to feel
which will be kind of we'll get to some
of that it's it's good to feel um
sometimes I can have trouble entering in
um through like worship or things
because I'm I'm so I don't know aware
you know was kind of my role and such
you know uh but not so today I've I mean
I might be negligent of you all honestly
you know I'm just sort of like well the
Lord be with you I hope this is fine for
you you know but I'm I'm kind of in my
own little world um I don't know but
maybe the the spirit will use that um so
um yeah anyway if you can I don't know
some of you have been here a while you
might tell my energy is a little bit
different and that would be um that
would be why so um let's see we're in
part four in our series The Bible
doesn't say that it's been a fun series
um we've basically just been looking at
these little turns of phrase you know
that are like they're just in they're in
the waters the of the Church of um kind
of broader Christian culture and even
just American culture um at least some
of these and um there these little you
know these little sayings these little
kind of uh they're usually pretty cliche
just from overuse um we've talked uh I
don't know like um what are some of
these y'all yall have been here um
everything happens for a
reason love the sinner hate the sin that
was was that last week I don't was last
yeah um I get lost because I'm I'm
usually working on multiple sermons at a
time so I can't you know what I mean
like I get lost in the midst of when do
we do what I have no idea but at some
point we touched on those themes and it
was fun um and so uh yeah so we just
been kind of unpacking them at times
we've had pretty heavy criticism of them
uh like love the sin or hate the sin
came down pretty hard on that one um but
uh the one tonight I'd say I I'll be a
little bit more gentle though I still
will I it needs discernment so the our
little phrase for tonight in the tit of
message is uh let go and let go
God oh yeah oh some of yall are I'm
getting almost the same reaction as love
this in or hate this in which is
interesting um I think it is a it is
painfully cliche um and uh but you know
the the writer David Foster Wallace said
uh things are often cliche um because
there's at least truth in them you know
there's something that resonates with
people otherwise no one would say it you
know um so obviously this can be tricky
when you're like putting it on other
people you know like hey just let that
you know whatever um but as we get into
some of the the um kind of the details
of this because I think yeah like I said
discernment is needed um I'm going to
start usually I start with the scripture
we're GNA what I want to do is kind of
set up the scriptures we'll get to um
and my point isn't to try to you know
neglect the Bible or something in my
sermon but I I I think often if I when I
throw a passage out there we're our
tendency is to read it in the same way
you know we we've heard many of us are
familiar with most if not all of the
script you know passages and so we hear
it and it just hits us away and we're
kind of like oh I know what that means
you know so what I want to do is save it
My Hope Is by kind of framing it then
when we get to it you can hear it you
know with new ears so to speak um so I
actually want to start with a um a quote
from um a a therapist and um his name is
Mark
Epstein um and it's titled advice not
given is his book advice not giving uh a
guide to getting over yourself and I
really found it it's quite insightful um
he's a practitioner of a different
religious tradition but he you know he's
he does um spend time in prayer and
silence and so it was a lot of the book
is him addressing um some of what he
feels like are the kind of the pitfalls
where people take actually kind of
little cliches not he doesn't use
exactly let go and let God as you'll see
but something like that and kind of we
just get wonky with it you know we get a
little off track like oh how is this
unhelpful and I thought he named it in
it was one of those aha moments where
you read a thing and you're like oh my
gosh I remember my son Oak was at soccer
practice and I'm sitting there I love
soccer practice where when I'm the one
not leading for my other son I lead I'm
the coach so you know I don't get to
read during that my younger son I'm
sitting in my little car just reading
away and I came across this I was like
oh my gosh at some point I going in a
sermon and I found it so
um so he um he he says uh this um he
writes for many people the most common
assumption is that letting go means
giving up the thing that's bothering
them this is going to be really key if
they're for example he goes through all
these examples you know if they're angry
with someone they tell themselves let go
of their anger you know if they're
anxious they try to let go of their
anxiety um if they're having disturbing
thoughts they Endeavor to dispatch them
if they're sad and upset with themselves
they try to surrender their unhappy
feelings but Letting Go does not mean
releasing the thing that's bothering in
you trying to get rid of it only makes
it stronger Letting Go has more to do
with
patience than it does with
release and I just read that I just
thought oh my goodness um because you
know this phrase I get we probably don't
perhaps use the whole phrase a lot you
know let go and let God or I don't know
maybe it was in the 90s or something
like really popular but it's kind of
fallen on harder times um at the very
least we say you know let Let It Go let
go let that go I mean sir I use that
like seven times a day with myself you
know I'm not even necessar putting it on
other just with me you know like Let It
Go Let It Go Let It Go um and as we'll
get to I there's a place for I'm not
trying to say kind of like no there's
nothing we need to let go of you know oh
no there's certainly is you know um but
the trick is
what what and what not and what do we
mean by letting go um
because what I what I kind of hear
Epstein naming here is is our he's
getting right to the root of some of our
misunderstanding um the the misuse of
the notion let go and let God um
basically the way that we tend to use it
as a is a spiritual mental
emotional Quick
Fix You know hey are you hurting today
you don't have to hurt anymore you just
let that go
right can you see where this gets kind
of like or as he name he uses all these
examples you know angry are you Ang are
you angry just let it go you know are
you sad you do you have um un kind of
disturbing thoughts unwelcome well just
let all that go just let it go and
they'll be gone look at he split you
know um this is where this is where we
get kind of uh I say sideways with that
and and so I think his Nuance here is
incredibly helpful because he's starting
to
get at H what are we often letting go of
and it's often our
feelings that's that's and really by
letting go what we mean is get them out
of here you know what I mean like I
don't want this anymore this feels
terrible um and so I'm going to dispatch
the feelings you know and and you can
see where this plays right into uh kind
of Christ faith and and religious
circles and even prayer you know because
then it's like God take this all from me
you know um and we're we're kind of um
maybe I can summarize it to say um when
used as an attempt to rid myself of
challenging feelings let go and let God
can become a dangerous form of spiritual
bypassing right where we're we talked
some kind of hit on this in a little bit
different angle uh maybe six weeks ago
or so like we we try to get around it
you know we try to instead of what we
named a few weeks ago was like going
through it and this is similar but now
just applied specifically to feelings
right where it's sort of like okay God
just take them just take it from me and
you can see where this actually gets a
little tricky because here we can use
very good
things um wonderful spiritual
practices uh
prayer worship uh
scripture you know memor memorization
and you know where of course those are
wonderful things I'm a pastor I'm not
like encouraging all not to do these
things um do these things but but but we
can kind of start all of a sudden trying
to use them in a way that gets us
around the jumble of what's going on you
know like I for example I knew um and
well actually a lot of pastors struggle
with this but I had a friend uh and
there's like this tend
tendy to because you know like well I
don't know pastoral work like there's
well it's you know it's good and it's
for people and so
um well I even I'll just speak for
myself I I noticed at times I can be
prone to a kind of um workaholism to a
always more to do you know but at times
as I've tuned into it over the years
it's not really or not always because
well I just have a lot to
do you know it's because I've got un
comfortable
feelings you know and so there's nothing
like more emails to just distract and
get me out of my right can you see where
this becomes problematic but then but
who could criticize me I'm working for
the church you know I mean the doing the
Lord's work or whatever like this is
where you know we have these ways of I
don't know even in in if you're you know
you're like I not a pastor how does this
apply to me I mean just think of you
know we do this with our own job jobs
and just like well I mean I can't be
there for the family I'm just you know
I've got so much to do and so but is it
could it be there's some things were
avoiding you know and that's the trick
right are we using these things as forms
of avoidance instead of like I mean for
example take prayer prayer at its best
is a
brutal but
good
honesty I mean if you're you come to
prayer and you're like feeling like you
kind of need to rage a little bit with
god well that's the best thing to do
right the honest move not go around it
you know I mean well Lord I just thank
you for all the blessings that you you
know what I mean and the whole time in
the background like as though God
doesn't know you know what I mean like
where you really are like and and not
that there's not a time to even in the
midst of your pain you know to Rejoice
or to say Lord I believe you're good you
know I'm not I'm not trying to put that
down but you can see where again it's
it's about kind of using this in a kind
of bypassed way so this kind of brings
us to what I'll call um the Paradox of
Letting Go as I was reflecting on
Epstein's quote I realize this is what's
so strange to let go rightly often
involves
holding right and as by and by holding I
mean we must in some sense kind of hold
or bear with or make space for that
which is difficult and
unpleasant you know we've got it which
is a strange thing to think yeah I
really need to to let that go which
we'll get to what what are we letting go
but then that means making room for my
feelings about the thing being okay
with where just wherever I am you know
and for all of us truthfully it's just
up and down isn't it there's the
mountain tops and the woo praise the
lord it's a great day you know a victory
a great day of Victory you know um at
least I don't know maybe depends our
percentage can depending on your season
of life and what's going on that can
sink low but but at other times right it
can happen but then there's of course
the
valleys and um it seems that's the the
trick is not trying to um dispel it let
it go I've had uh in fact so yeah
there's lots of ways to mess up letting
go in fact I I came across a funny
little um Instagram post I'm not big on
the socials uh I I've set up all of my
posts to go throughout the week I do
that on Sunday so I schedule them and
then I check in occasionally just to see
if anyone said something to me that's
about I do my best to stay away from the
socials I not a fan but I have recently
Maggie and I my wife um when we're just
exhausted at night we will take like 20
minutes or something and we'll get the
kids down and then we'll just watch like
funny Instagram videos it's a delight
um and like and we make it we make sure
like if it's anything serious we just
swipe you know someone's like three keys
to getting better in your life we're
like no no you know um but I saw this
one uh one funny video was a woman um
probably mid 20s or so you can see kind
of her husband or partner someone in the
background you know and she says uh me
and you know my husband we're we decided
you not to have kids and uh it's you can
imagine like everyone's taking it really
hard my um my mother's like freaking out
my grandmother's like guilt tripping me
and I mean the worst part of course the
kids like they hate the idea they are
not for this at all you know um I think
that's a good example you know of
letting go just like we got to be
careful here what are you know what are
we what are we talking about so um okay
so if it's not that right if let go and
let God in a profoundly unhealthy way is
I've got challenging feelings I want to
get rid of them so I'm just giving them
all to you Lord and hopes that we can
kind of stuff these down which is really
what we're doing you um if it's not that
what is it I this is I think a a I
wrestled with how to say this but I'll
because I think it's can be so
comprehensive but let me just throw a
few words out there anytime you see
commas you know I'm just throwing out
words and seeing if anything connects um
letting go is releasing my compulsive
need to enter the commas judge control
fix blame distract or just generally
feel better
now you know what I mean and is this not
the root of all addiction of course you
know what I mean is oh I don't want to
go there so I'll just do this thing this
makes me feel better now you know um and
I thought the trick is um I mean in in a
lot of
ways I think this
is I mean you can see with the word
surrender this is where we're starting
to come we'll get to our scriptures in
just a moment because I mean this is
this is not some I don't know weird
therapeutic sermon that has nothing to
do with Christian faith oh no no no no
like this goes right to the roots of
what it really means to follow Jesus
Christ to to utterly surrender ourself
because I think really honestly what
we're letting go of is like my goodness
what aren't we letting go of right so I
I've been kind of thinking about it it's
almost reverse of what we do like we
hold on to everything and everyone else
in the world you know what I mean just
this like if something's going good it's
like yes lock this down you know I mean
control it you or a person and we get
into the kind of weird codependent thing
you know just I need you you know and we
just we it's like we're clinging and
grasping at everything and everyone in
the world and then our feelings you know
we're just like get these away I'm
letting those go you know when actually
I I I imagine um or I say I've in my own
journey of following Jesus what he keeps
inviting me to is to let all of that
other stuff just go which doesn't mean
again like dismissing you know ending
your marriage I'm just letting you go
you know like you get it you know what I
mean but it's but it's letting go of
this need to
control to
blame to those stories that's something
I have to let go of all the time I mean
hundred thousand times a day my
storyline can you believe them what they
did and how they did
and you
never ending just never ending right but
of course those aren't the things we
want to let go of we no I need that you
know but I just I need to let go of this
depression you um and yeah well let's
get to our our um
scriptures um 1 Peter chapter 4:12 dear
friends do not be surprised at the fiery
ordeal woo that's intense language you
know at the fiery ordeal of come on you
to test you as though something strange
were happening to you anyone going
through a fiery ordeal or have been
through one in recent memory um all the
time you know this is the key right what
we're really tempted to do is just like
this must be happening and but if I if I
only I could just let it go it would all
stop and be better you know it's this
kind of need to like control the
situation and instead of
like okay okay
um this this is it's it is you know what
I mean and I receive
it um and I trust God that you've got
something for me in the midst of this
thing that I can't like change or fix or
blame or I you know just is um Romans
12:12 be joyful in Hope patient in
Affliction faithful in prayer I thought
like this suddenly these kind of
passages honestly I think I read these
in the past before kind of Epstein's
quote and I just didn't quite get it I
don't know like patient and affliction
okay just kind of like grin and barar it
you know or something or just kind of
like it's okay oh I can take it or you
know but suddenly this opened up my eyes
to it of kind of like hey I mean because
you know the secret is like it will pass
you know it'll pass but in the meantime
we just got to
like bear with with it patient in
Affliction patient in the suffering this
is exactly what Epstein said let Letting
Go has more to do with
patience than it does with release it's
being okay with what is and with my
feelings around
it um Ephesians 4:2 with all humility
and gentleness with patience bearing
with one another in
love anyone you're bearing with in love
maybe a few people bearing with you in
love of course
um Paul here has in mind you know this
others you know our relationship with
people which is true but kind of taking
that phrase bearing with and applying it
kind of dropping it into our context
here I mean you can see where the
invitation is to um sometimes we're
bearing with our own life our own life
situation our circumstances our feelings
around our life we're we're bearing with
it for um as long as I can remember I
have struggled deeply with um
anxiety and I didn't even know this
because well I'd always struggled with
it so you know it was just my normal but
I weird I won't go into the whole
backstory but like five years ago I took
a supplement it was supposed to help me
with something else and then it like
reduced my anx xiety which I did not
know I had like intense I mean I get
every human as like some anxiety but
this you know mine was like sort of you
know level seven all day every day you
know just like an anxious person you
know but I didn't know it so I took that
supplement and I was like oh my
gosh just is this how people live
sometimes I couldn't believe it I worked
in the corporate world oh like back
before this oh it's hellish for me I
mean it just I mean conference calls I'm
a project manager I'm leading the call I
don't like phon I can't see the people I
don't know what they're doing or feeling
or saying or you know what I mean or I
can hear them I guess but I can't read
their body language you know just but
then I'm and then as a project manager
I'm like responsible for everyone's
everything but I don't I'm not them but
I'm responsible for the outcome you know
it's just like oh dear lord and have it
was rough so I take this supplement and
it's just like my life like changes you
know so fast forward five years um to
like six seven weeks ago and uh my
little supplement stopped
working
oh no I was I mean because honestly I
don't know if I would have started the
table without that you know mean it's
like this is church church plan in
general it's tough you know times um at
least for this St and I was like
freaking out I like oh no now in the
back of my mind I knew like okay there's
like medication stuff and there's like
option you know what I mean but what was
interesting was I I was thinking about
not this sermon per se but like these
themes and such have been meditating on
these things for a while you know
there's writers who've been very helpful
for me in this um Richard Roar um
Cynthia borol uh that's I'm saying her
name wrong but I don't know how to
pronounce her last name I think it's
French Borat I don't know um uh but uh
Thomas keing in his book um on cering
prayer I practice cering prayer so a
time of Silence every morning you know
and so in essence it's sort of
everything we've been talking about like
I kind of I know it at least up here you
know the trick of course is like living
it so like six seven weeks ago I was
like
well here we
go and I just
um was like you know I'm gonna see what
is this what's this trying to tell me
like what's going on under the hood I've
been kind of you know taking which by
the way I'm not putting down like
supplements or medication or anything
you know like there's a time and a place
um for sure
but for me I felt like the invitation
was like let me press in this little bit
so I just had this kind of choking
anxiety I do things with my throat when
I feel this kind of it's like a I just
want to make sounds I remember greeting
back there like six seven weeks ago and
I was trying not to do that while I
greeted each of you because I'm anxious
like when I come into this space you
know um trying not to try to hide and
I've learned through you know 39 years
like I can hide it um I was struggling
and so I decided just let me sit with
this let me let me kind of welcome
instead of again letting go of the
anxiety so I get rid of it you know like
no let me sit with it and so for like
two weeks I was just kind of trying to
welcome it and like breathe and relax
and like you know and um nothing changed
you
know and then I woke up one morning and
I was like I don't know it was like it
was a little bit
better and then like later the afternoon
it got worse again and then kind of
better and then worse again and it was
just sort of riding these waves but I
started to realize actually the
invitation what I kind of started to
learn was it wasn't that I need to let
go of the anxiety there was other things
I needed and will continue to need to
let go of that in essence that's um
driving much of it for me is I feel out
of control in the world I can't control
all of you I can barely control me and
the world seems crazy and it's
difficults and I'm struggling you know
and it became a powerful kind of
noticing practice of like oh feel like
I'm about to choke there it
is what do I need to let go of
now
um and since then I'm just riding the
waves it's better at times it's worse at
times I'm just riding the waves
um and I could just go on and on with
examples I mean you know these
things we have to let go of um I was
reading through my I have a night
Journal it's only a journal that I write
in um well at night um when I wake up at
like 3:00 a.m you know just anxious as
oh my God and there's like something
spin you know and I just grab it and I
just start so it's like the most like my
normal Journal sort of up and down
there's good things there's you know but
this is like the crazy Journal it's
insane you know so I was going back and
reading from like 5 six years ago
and so right when I was our whole
history I was like planted a different
Church community um and I was reading
those posts and I was like oh my gosh
that poor Brett so eaten up with a fear
of failure I mean I was
terrified of my church like launch out
and then it just like you know I mean
like oh I was eaten
up what what was going on on there's so
much there to let go of um and I'm still
a work in progress but I'm
better and the and why it's
just you know what it just is going to
be I'm going to try my best you all will
try your best and the Lord will work you
know and good things will happen and bad
things will happen you know I have no
idea what 5 years from now hold it's you
know um Let It Go Let It Go go Let it go
I could just keep going but I'm not um
so I'm curious you know this is
rhetorical but what is it for
you right what is it for you what's the
invitation tonight what do you need to
let go of is it so and so's opinion
about you is it such and such outcome
that you just need that to happen in the
right way is you know is that person
that are acting crazy and is driving you
crazy and you know what's the what is it
what is it what's the thing to let
because there is something for each of
us to let go of
um while at the same time welcoming this
the trick right
welcoming and saying okay Lord's with me
with whatever I'm feeling this due shall
pass this D Shall
Pass
yeah um so that's
it yeah in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit amen amen um so
as we come to the table of the Lord Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
and the bread the blood of Christ and
the wine uh we do it uh we just do it as
ourselves we do it as the uh the
beautiful broken delightful messes that
we are you know and we do we we come
forward in honesty and vulnerability um
with all of our feelings you know some
of you tonight you're full of Faith
you're carrying the torch for the rest
of us you know bless you we love you
we're so glad that you're in that place
others of you you're like limping to the
doors you know not literally maybe but
you know emotionally you're barely here
um you you don't have to pretend you
know you can come to receive Christ you
take in Christ and I believe when we
take communion something's like
something happens there's a the posit of
the spirit of God or something you know
I'm I'm a bit woo woo I am I admit it um
and something yeah something beautiful
happens so as as you come forward
tonight um I encourage you to do it in
that kind of honest you know place you
receive the thing you need to receive
and let go of the thing you need to let
go of so the way we'll do this is um
we'll just go row by row start in the
front we'll just kind of work our way
back so as one one group finishes the
next row can you know come on up um we
practice what's called an Open Table me
if you're here tonight in in your heart
you're like I want to participate I want
to connect with Jesus maybe you walk
through those doors and you're like I
don't even know a lot about Christianity
or whatever we're doing here um but
something in you wants to connect with
the Risen Jesus then you're you're
welcome to to come forward with whatever
Faith you know you have um the red is
wine the white is grape juice so you've
been warned and um finally you can just
partake whenever you'd like uh no one
will like lead you through the exact
moment you know of the of the taking so
this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord It's Made ready
for those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you you
who have much Faith you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
for
so just in the spirit of reflection um I
don't know about you but my heart and my
brain are just kind of swirling around
the things that I mean my list of things
to let go feels
long and so rather than standing and
singing I thought maybe let's just take
a big deep breath
and
let's just reflect just be in the space
be silent if you
want and let God speak to you in the way
that God
[Music]
does you brought me to the end of my
self and this has been the long
Road just when my
Hallelujah was
tired you gave me a new
song I'm
Letting
[Music]
Go I'm
let
go I'm
Letting
Go falling into
[Music]
you I confess I still get
scared
sometimes but perfect love comes
rushing in
and all the lies that screamed inside go
silent the moment you
begin I'm
Letting
[Music]
Go I'm
Letting
[Music]
Go I'm let
go falling into
[Music]
you
me of things forgotten you
unwi
me till I'm totally undone
and with your arms around me fear was no
match for your love now you w
me you
remind
me of things forgotten you
unwind
me until I'm totally
undone with your arms around me fear was
no match for Your Love Now you won
me I'm
Letting
[Music]
Go I'm
Letting
[Music]
Go I'm
Letting Go
[Music]
oh falling into
you thank you everybody so much for
coming tonight I know it wasn't the
ideal weather but we are very glad that
you're here if this is your first time
coming we would like to get to know you
uh you can either scan the QR code
behind me or there's a little table in
the back um we really just want to reach
out to you our leadership team will'll
get to know you get in touch to so that
you can be a part of the community as
well um one thing that Brett mentioned
in the sermon just now is making space
uh to take a moment um if anybody needs
to make that space and needs somebody to
pray with you I would love to do that um
I will be here after the service please
just feel free to come find me and we
can just take a moment and sit in
whatever season that you are in
um we are a Christ centered community
and the only way that we can do that is
with generosity if you feel compelled to
contribute to the church in any way
again scan the QR code or there's uh a
note at the back of this uh church as
well um one thing that we do here um
that I loved when I first started coming
um is our benefit addiction at the end
of the service um if you feel compelled
I would love for everybody to stand and
put their hands out in a posture of
receiving um so that we can send you out
into your week
[Music]
ahead you are a child of God you are a
child of God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst day so
as you go into your week ahead with its
yet to be determined highs and lows and
and everything in between go filled with
the assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed and have a great week
everyone I'm Let It Go
I'm
Letting
[Music]
Go I'm Letting
Go
falling
[Music]
you
oh